2014 July 5th the Ukrainian army entered
slavyansk city in eastern ukraine they
gathered all the locals in Millennium
Square then they organized the public
crucifixion of the son of a pro-russia
militant he was only three years old
refugee galina posniak told the story to
russia's first TV channel in fact this
incident never happened I visited
slavyansk there is no lenin square in
reality galina's husband was an active
pro-russia militant indian boss this is
just one of many examples Ukraine's been
suffering from Russian propaganda and
fake news for four years now but Russia
is not the only player in this space
fake news is happening all around the
world we all know about fake news we see
it and read it all the time but the
thing about fake news that we don't
always know what is fake and what is
real but we base our decisions on facts
we get from the press and social media
when facts are false decisions are wrong
a lot of people stop believing any one
at all and this is even more dangerous
they easily become prey to populist sin
elections or even take up arms fake news
is not only bad for journalism it's a
threat for democracy and society four
years ago unmarked soldiers entered the
Crimean Peninsula and at the same time
Russian media was going crazy with fake
news about Ukraine so a group of
journalists including me started a
website to investigate these fake news
we called it stop
fake the idea was simple take a piece of
news check it with verifiable proofs
like photos videos and other strong
evidence if it turns out to be fake we
put it on our website
now stop fake is an informational hub
which analyzes propaganda in all its
phases we have 11 language versions we
have millions of views we have taught
more than 10,000 people how to
distinguish truth from false and we
teach fact checkers all around the world
stopfake has uncovered more than 1,000
fakes about ukrainian we've identified
18 narratives created using the fake
news such as Ukraine is a fascist state
a failed state a state run by a hunter
who came to power as a result of a coup
d'etat we prove that it's not bad
journalism it's a deliberate act of
misinformation fake news is a powerful
weapon in information warfare but there
is something we can do about it
we all have smartphones well we see
something interesting it's often
automatic we just click and buy set
alone but how can you not be a part of
fake news first if it's too dramatic too
emotional to clickbait then it's very
likely that it isn't true the truth is
born sometimes manipulations are always
sexy they are designed to captivate you
do your research this is the second
point very simple look at other sites
check out alternative news sources
Google names addresses license plates
experts and authors don't just believe
check it's the only way to stop this
culture of fake news this information
warfare is not only about fake new
our society depends on trust trust in
our institutions in science trust in our
leaders trust in our news outlets and
it's on us to find a way to rebuild
trust
because fake news destroys it so ask
yourself what have you lost your faith
in where has trust been ruined for you
and what are you going to do about it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]